le projet de loi destiné à combattre la
violence dans les stades a été adopté
hier à l'assemblée nationale c'est la
réponse directe des députés aux
incidents récents qui s'était produit
souvenez vous à marseille au parc
laurent frédéric bollée c'était le 28
août dernier le match psg caen au parc
des princes est émaillée de violents
affrontements entre supporters et forces
de l'ordre ces incidents heureusement
rare dans le football français ont été
le point de départ d'une volonté de
réaction des pouvoirs publics dès le
lendemain le ministère des sports et de
la jeunesse décide d'un futur projet de
loi destiné à combattre le hooliganisme
là quelques agités qui sont une infime
minorité et qui viennent dans les stades
non pas pour le sport mais qui viennent
pour laisser libre cours à des instincts
que je ne donne même pas qualifié ceci
est intolérable
il faut qu'il soit mis fin et dans les
plus brefs délais et de la façon la plus
ferme possible
hier l'assemblée nationale a donc voté
ce projet de loi 15 jours après le sénat
une large majorité s'est dégagée puisque
seul le parti communiste a voté contre
concrètement le projet réprime l'état
d'ivresse dans les stades ainsi que
l'introduction de boissons les coupables
sont passibles de 50 mille francs
d'amendé
l'incitation à la haine ou à la violence
à l'égard de l'arbitré d'un joueur ou
d'une autre personne peut entraîner cent
mille francs d'amendé
les députés ont rajouté un amendement
visant à prohiber le port ou
l'exhibition d'un signe raciste ou
xénophobe
avec surcoût comparution immédiate sans
écran et trois ans de prison en cas
d'introduction de fusées susceptibles de
constituer une arme dangereuse
enfin l'interdiction de stade en cas
d'actes de violence
bourré jusqu'à cinq ans